[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم تتواصل التظاهرات التي تشهدها
العراق والتي بدات مطلب تدعو لتوفير
الكهرباء والخدمات ثم امتدت لتنادي
باصلاحات سياسيه واسعه ففي محافظه البصره
يواصل محتجون اعتصامهم امام مبنى المحافظه
منذ ايام رافعين شعارات تطالب بتحسين
الخدمات ومكافحه الفساد نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لنناقش في
محورين هل سيؤدي الحراك الحالي في العراق
الى تغيير شامل في
البلاد وهل تستطيع القوى السياسيه
الاستجابه لمطالب التغيير في ظل الاوضاع
الحاليه
[موسيقى]
تظاهرات العراق اصبحت ككره الثلج
المتدحرجه فبعد ان كانت مطالب المتظاهرين
مجرد علاج مشكله تردي الكهرباء والخدمات
بشكل عام اصبحت بالاضافه الى ذلك طبعا
تطالب بتنفيذ اصلاحات سياسيه تمس شكل
النظام الذي عرفه العراق منذ عام 2003 ف
دعوات للاصلاح تتزايد يوما بعد يوم في
التظاهرات التي تشهدها بغداد ومحافظات
الوسط والجنوب العراقي ومنها البصره التي
تشهد اعتصامات وسجلت سقوط ثلاثه قتلى فضلا
عن الجرحى منذ اندلاع التظاهرات قبل نحو
شهر تقرير زياد
بركات فاض الكيل فلم تعد المظاهرات تكفي
في البصره خيضت حروب الداخل طيله ولايتي
المالك باسم المكون الغالي فيها وفي مدن
اخرى لكن الحال لم يتغير بل ازداد سوءا
فالفقر الى ازدياد والخدمات الى تدهور
والماء الى تلوث والكهرباء الى انقطاع
فاذا هي زائر نادر الحضور في واحده من
اكبر الدول انتاجا للنفط ليس ثمه من حل
اذا سوى
التظاهر نور
الم هذا ما فعلته مدن الجنوب العراقي كما
بغداد وسواها وفي ك اعاده للازمه في
البلاد الى جذرها الواقعي حيث المعادله
بالغه الوضوح حاكم فاسد يؤجج نار الطائفيه
ويتخذها درعا وغطاء
ليعيثوا المجلس البلدي في الفاو وكانوا
قبلا سيروا المظاهرات واشتبكوا مع الامن
وسقط منهم قتيل وجرحى قبل ذلك ايضا
وتحديدا في تموز الماضي كانت منطقه
المدينه في محافظه البصره منطلقا لمظاهرات
مطلب توفير الخدمات لا تحسينها اضافه الى
تعيين ابناء المحافظه التي تعوم فوق بحيره
من النفط في شركات الطاقه الموجوده في
المحافظه انذاك تصدت قوات الامن للمظاهرات
فقتل احد المتظاهرين ما اجج نار الغضب
هناك سرعان ما انتقل الى كل مدن المحافظه
وبلداتها قطعوا الطرق طالبوا بمسائل
المرجعيات الدينيه قبل السياسيه ومحاسبتها
لينتهي الامر بمدن العراق الكبرى من
الجنوب الى العاصمه وهي تغص بالشباب فماذا
يفعل العبادي ومن وراءه ليبقوا الوصفه
الجاهزه هي الاصلاح وبذل الوعود لتنفيذها
وتلك جاءت من المرجعيه الشيعيه العليا
تامر فينفذ يلغي مناصب نواب الرئيس ورئيس
الوزراء يتحدث عن الغاء المحاصصه الطائفيه
وان له ذلك
وما يفعله بوحي من مرجعيه شيعيه لا تخفى
اذا تجاوز العراقيون هذا وذاك فان ثمه ما
يزيد مهمه العباد المفترضه صعوبه هناك
تراجع في اسعار النفط تضخم مهول في
الوظائف الوهميه في الجيش والحشد الشعبي
كما في الادارات المدنيه وانفلات للشباب
العراقي من المعادلات الطائفيه فالمطالب
عابره للطوائف وقد تخرج عن السيطره فتهوي
النظام الذي يسعى لتقنين وثمه ما هو اكثر
تعقيدا ايضا صراع مراكز قوى منها المالكي
انه الان في ايران يخوض حربه ضد الجميع
مستقويه بمرجعيات شيعيه اخرى من بين هذا
كله قد يولد عراق
جديد نرحب بضيوفنا في هذه الحلقه من بغداد
جاسم الموسوي المحلل السياسي من عمان احمد
الابيض الكاتب والباحث حث السياسي ومن
بيروت عزه شبندر السياسي العراقي المستقل
نبدا من بغداد سيد جاسم الموسوي هذا
الحراك الغاضب في العراق برايك هل يمكن ان
يقود الى تغيير حقيقي في
البلاد بكل تاكيد هذا الحراك انت تسميه
الغاضب انا اسميه المتفاعل مع الاصلاحات
التي بدات جاوب فيها الطبقه السياسيه
ومنها الدكتور العبادي ومن المرجعيه مساحه
التصاعد الاحتجاجات تتسع في العراق لان
هناك مساحه واسعه بين الحوار الشارع
واجابه القوى السياسيه والدليل الاصلاحات
التي بدات تتوالى حقيقه وتستجيب لكل ما
يطالب به الشارع ضمن الدستور والقانون نحن
لن نصل الى جغرافيا خانقه تتشابه مع ما
حدث في كثير من الدول لدينا نظام انتقل من
عصر الى عصر بعد 2003 لدينا دستور تم
الاستفتاء عليه نعم لدينا اخطاء ارتكبت في
تركيبه النظام السياسي ولكن الثابت في
العراق هو النظام السياسي في هيكله العام
والمتغير او الذي يمكن تجريف هو القوى
السياسيه التي يثبت انها سواء ارتكبت
عمليات فساد او عمليات تخالف القانون
والدستور لذلك هذا لن يتصاعد لن يكون هناك
خوف في العراق انما يكون قلق من قبل القوى
السياسيه باعتبار ان المطالب هي مطالب
خدميه لم لم تكن مطالب سياسيه لاسقاط
النظام كما يشير لها او اشار لها بعض
التقارير التي وردت سواء في تقريركم او
التقارير بعض القنوات العراق عابر لكل ما
هو خطر وهو باتجاه التصحيح في المسارات
الخاطئه هناك بدات مسافات تقترب بين راس
الهرم والقاعده الافقيه راس الهرم صحيح
امامه كوابح لعمليه تصحيح بعض المسارات
الخاطئه ولكن ايضا القاعده الافقيه قاعده
واعيه بدات تتفهم ضروره ان تتانى وان
تستمع لاننا لا نريد ان ندخل في فوضه
يستفيد او يستثمرها بعض المتصيدين في
المياه العكره انت تتحدث عن عن عن مطالب
خدميه وتتحدث عن تفاعل بين القياده
السياسيه والمتظاهرين ولكن اذا سالنا سيد
احمد
الابيض هل تعتقد بان الاستجابه لجزء من
مطالب هؤلاء المتظاهرين ايه
يعني كفيل ب ان ان ان تقف المظاهرات وهذا
الحراك عند مستوى
معين الحقيقه لازم المره نصف طبيعه الحراك
في العراق الفهم الخاطئ انه تقف مساله
الخدمات اساسيه في هذا مساله الخدمات قد
تكون الشراره التي قد يعني اوقدت هذا
الحراك هذا الحراك الحقيقه حول وبقدره
بقدره الشباب العراقي حوله من كون صراع
طائفي كان يج يجري في البلاد على كل
المستويات للاسف وحاولت الطبقه السياسيه
الحاليه ترسيخه ليكون لها ساتر للاف سد
والفساد ولكن الذي حصل تم بقدره هذا الشعب
وشبابه حولو الى صراع شبه ايديولوجي يرتكز
على رفض الراديكاليه بكل انواعها من كل
الجهات الراديكاليه ليست حصرا على جهه دون
اخرى في ازاء التحرر وانتزاع القرار
الوطني في هذا البلد هذا هو الفهم 80% من
الذين يقودون الحراك هم شباب دون 30 سنه
ليس هنالك امكانيه باتهامهم بانه ينتموا
على سبيل المثال الى حزب البعث لان
اعمارهم كانت بحدود العشر سنوات عندما
غادر هذا الحزب ولا يمكن اتهامهم بشيء اخر
كالطائرات الاوسط هذا عزز قدرتهم على
الانتصار غطاهم الذي مكنهم من الوصول
واسماع صوتهم وانين الى الطبقه السياسيه
وكان العلم العراقي هذه هي فلسفه سريعه
للصراع في العراق ويجب ان يفهم الحقيقه من
الجميع ان هذا الصراع لن يتاخر في تحقيق
الاهداف الاساسيه بان يكون هناك عراق واحد
قادر على العيش والتنعم بقدراته وخيراته
هو اللافت للانتباه سيد عزه شبندر ان
الاستجابه لهذه
التظاهرات كانت سريعه وكان لافت للانتباه
بصراحه ان مجلس الوزراء بالاجماع
تجاوب مع ما قاله السيد العبادي مجلس
النواب ايضا بالاجماع
بتقديرك مع ذلك استمرت التظاهرات لم تعد
مجرد
خدميه هل ترى لها افق يتجاوز هذا
المنحى شكرا لك في الحقيقه ما يجري في
العراق الان ربيع
عراقي وبعد ان عجز الربيع العربي عن
اختراق
اسوار العراق
المحصنه لابد وان يبدا ربيعا عراقيا
وينتهي بما يطلب هؤلاء
المتظاهرون الفصل بين الخدمات وبين النظام
السياسي فصل غير
دقيق نعم نبدا بالكهرباء وتتوسع المطالب
فتذهب الى
الخدمات ولكن اكيد ستطال ان النظام
السياسي لانه الخدمات مترديه بسبب الفساد
وسوء الاختيار والفساد وسوء الاختيار انما
جاءت به
المحاصصه وهذه المحاصصه
ارتضتها الكتل لحد الان انا اختلف مع بعض
الزملاء بان الاستجابه كانت
سريعه هذه ليست استجا اجابه لما يريده
الشارع وحتى طريقه تعبير الشارع في
الحقيقه عن مطالبه
الحقيقيه لم تعبر عن الوجع الحقيقي والخلل
الحقيقي الذي انتج كل هذا التردي وهذا
التدهور في العراق
اليوم نطالب
مثلا نطالب
بمحاكمه الفاسدين من
الوزراء نطالب
النواب ولكن
نغفل ان هؤلاء الوزراء هم
موظفون لدى
كتل الوزير لا يستطيع ان يفسد كما يشاء من
دون ان يطمئن ان هناك مظله سياسيه تحميه
وتقيه من الحساب والعقاب اذا المدان هو
النظام اصلا تركيبته طريقه بناء النظام هي
الخلل وهي التي ولذلك سيد شبندر ولذلك
عندما عندما يعني عندما نطالع عندما نطالع
الشعارات
المرفوعه وهنا اعود مره اخرى للسيد جاسم
الموسوي عندما نرجع للشعارات المرفوعه
نراها عابره للطائفيه وقويه في مضمونها
تتحدث عن مثل ما قال سيد شبان تتحدث عن
ضروره محاسبه الفاسدين محاكمتهم
ايه تجاوز المحاصصه انهاء توظيف ابناء
المسؤولين
واقربائهم وضع حد لهذه الحراسات المضخمه
للمسؤولين السياسيين للميزانيات المفتوحه
ولانفع غير المراقب اذا لا تستطيع مثل ما
قال سيد شبندر ان تتحدث عن خدمات او تحسين
خدمات دون ان نمس جوهر هذا النظام الذي
قام على على عمليه سياسيه مثل ما تسمى في
العراق قامت اساسا
على تغطيه البعض للبعض وتغطيه فاسدين
لفاسد في السنوات
الماضيه لا استاذ محمد لانها انطلقت من
الوسط والجنوب والذي تعود ان لا يتمتع
بثقافه الانا والاختلاف مع الاخر انما
الانا والاخر في وطن واحد وهذا ما تعودنا
عليه في الوسط والجنوب يعني هو هذا الحراك
اصلا يخت عن الحراك الذي اشار اليه السيد
شاه بندر والذي كان جزء من هذا النظام
عندما يطالب بربيع الربيع دائما يعرف
بالمنطقه العربيه هو ضد نظام استبدادي نحن
لا توجد لدينا دكتاتوريه واذا كانت لدينا
دكتاتوريه رمزيه يجب اسقاطها فانا اعتقد
الشابندر كانان جزء من هذه الدكتاتوريه
لذلك نحن لسنا في ربيع نحن في اعاده ترتيب
اوراق النظام السياسي للاخطاء التي ارتكبت
نتيجه وجود بعض بعض القوى السياسيه التي
فرضت المحاصصه الخاطئه والتي شوهت
الديمقراطيه لكن على العموم نحن في نظام
ديمقراطي انت ماذا تسمي لهذه التظاهرات
عندما ترفع شعارات متنوعه مختلفه من اقصى
اليمين تتواجد في كل الساحات دون ان تتعرض
الى اي مضايقه ماذا تسمي عندما يخرج رئيس
الوزراء ويسمي هذه التظاهرات بانها ثوره
ولكن ثوره على النظام
الاداري اسمحلي فقط سيد موسوي من صعب ان
ان تعتبر عدم قمع المظاهرات وكانه نوع من
اسداء المعروف لهؤلاء اي سياسي كان سيواجه
كان اسمحلي اي سياسي كان سيواجه هؤلاء
الغاضبين من الشباب كان
سيقم السلطه سياسيه في مجابهه مع مدنيين
عزل وسيكون هناك بحر من الدماء يعني ايضا
كان هناك نوع من الواقعيه في التعامل مع
الموضوع لا لا بدايه التظاهرات استاذ محمد
بدايه صغيره جدا كان لو كان هناك نوايا
للنظام في قمحها او للاحزاب في قمحها ل
تمكنوا منذ الوهله الاولى انا اقول لك
هناك عوامل مهمه جدا ساعدت صانع القرار
السياسي على ان تكون هناك مظاهرات تعطيه
الصلاحيه والقوه لان يتمتع بتقنين وتقليل
وترشيق هذ هذا الانتفاخ الكبير في جسد
الحكومه التي تشكلت على اساس التوافقات
يجب ان يكون هناك كردي ويجب ان يكون هناك
شيعي ويجب ان يكون هناك سني اليوم الخطوات
التي اتخذها الدكتور حيدر العبادي هي
داعمه لرؤيه ومشروع الدوله العراقيه التي
حقيقه جاهده وناضل كثير من هؤلاء اما كلمه
الفساد المطلق وحقيقه فساد الدوله وما
شابه ذلك انا اعتقد هذا تعميم يراد منه
خلط الاوراق واضح جدا ان هناك فريقان فريق
يريد الاصلاح ولا يتمكن الا من خلال وجود
دعم المرجعيه والمتظاهرين وفريق اخر يريد
ان يحاول على الحصول على بعض المكاسب
نتيجه وجود فوبيا دواعش وهذا التهديد الذي
حقيقه تحت مرمى النار لا تزال العمليه
السياسيه في العراق منذ 2003 الى الان هي
تحت مرمى النار لذلك انا اعتقد هناك مساحت
وهناك جناحان الجناح الوسط هو الاخطر الذي
يحاول ان يخلط بين الاول والاخر ويحاول ان
يصور للعالم ان ما يجري في العراق هي
تتشابه مع تنسيقيات سوريا وليبيا مع ذلك
واضح ان حجم حجم حجم المطالب سيد موسوي
كبير ويبدو ان هناك امال عريض لدى هؤلاء
المتظاهرين نريد ان نعرف بعد الفاصل هل
القوى السياسيه العراقيه قادره على
الاستجابه لهذه المطالب الجارفه على ما
يبدو لتغيير الاوضاع في البلاد لنا عوده
بعد فاصل نرجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها افاق التغيير
السياسي في العراق في ضوء هذه المظاهرات
التي تخرج غاضبه على الفساد
والمفسدين في العراق سييد احمد
الابيض رئيس الوزراء حيدر العبادي قال
بانه ماضي في هذه العمليه حتى وان كلفه
ذلك حياته ويبدو الان من خلال ما يجري في
العراق وكان هناك مايسترو واحد وهو
العبادي في علاقه استجابه وتجاوب مع هؤلاء
المتظاهرين هل تعتقد بانه قادر على ان
يواصل ذلك في ظل ما يبدو نوع من البهته او
نوع من الجمود لدى القوى السياسيه
الاخرى استاذ محمد الحقيقه احنا خرجنا في
الجمعات الثلاثه التي مضت وكنا مع الشارع
والتمس ماذا يريد الشارع حقيقه ولدينا
تواصل مع كل الاخوه في المحافظات المشكله
هي ليست
في طرح الشعارات من قبل السيد العبادي
والوعود هنالك مسائل اساسيه قسم من عندها
الحقيقه قسم من عندها وضحت من خلال طلب
المرجعيه الدينيه في النجف للسيد العبادي
هناك خارطه ال طريق المفهوم الاساسي في
هذا الاصلاح هو اقتلاع الفاسد وتعيين
الكفوء النزيه من خارج رحم الاحزاب هذه
قضيه اساسيه الثاني الحقيقه الذي اتضح في
الاسبوع الماضي هو التغيير الهيكليه
التامه للقضاء على مستوى الاشخاص وليس على
مستوى البنيان هذا مطلب اساسي الحقيقه وجب
على السيد العبادي ان ينش به في هذا
الاسبوع وصولا الى الجمعه القادمه وسوف
تلاحظ في هذا الحراك في كل جمعه هنالك
مطلب محدد معناه هنالك وعي جماهيري متقدم
الحقيقه على الطبقه السياسيه اليوم الطبقه
السياسيه قسمين قسم يتربص بالسيد العبادي
ويريد اسقاطه وحتى من داخل انصاره يعني
موجودين وقسم اخر لا يقول لك ليترك السيد
العبادي ساتر لامتصاص كما يعرف بالفر زون
لامتصاص الضربات ضربات الجماهير ونتظر
ماذا سوف يحصل بعد شهر او شهرين لكن ارد
وان اؤكد الرهان على التسويف والرهان على
انه هذا الحراك سوف ينتهي رهان خاطئ وخاسر
وحتى وان قمع ولاحظ استشهد لك بتجربه ماذا
حصل في كربلاء في كربلاء الحقيقه تم
استخدام المياه الساخنه والغازات وحتى
الهراوات ضد المتظاهرين ولكن لم يتوقف
الحراك اذا هنالك مع في في خلجات
المتظاهرين الان والحراك مساله اساسيه انه
انصاف الثورات صاف الانتفاضه هو انتحار
للشعوب اي بمعنى ان لم نحقق ما نريد فلن
نعود هذا هذا ما لمسناه من الشباب الحقيقه
الذي يصر واللي انا وضحت لك انه اعمارهم
دون ال 30 سنه هؤلاء في عنفوانه اليوم
ولذلك الحكومه حسنا تفعل الان ولكن
البروسيجر الخطوات يجب ان تكشف للناس ما
هي الخطوات نحن نتحدث الان عن شعارات
قلصنا مجلس وزراء لغي نواب ما شابه ذلك
ليس هو هذا الاساس الاساس باقامه العدل
والعدل يتحقق من خلال اقامه قضاء حقيقي
هذه مساله اساسيه وبوابه للاصلاح العام
ولكن هل هل هل بوابه الاصلاح
هذه قادر على ان يدخلها سيد عزه شمندر ان
ان ان تدخلها هذه القوى السياسيه لان قوى
سياسيه تربت طوال السنوات الماضيه على
الاستفاده على التعامل مع الدوله كغنيمة
جاز المسؤولين تذهل على مليارات الدولارات
التي بعثرت طوال السنوات الماضيه هل هذه
الطبقه السياسيه التي افسدت قادره على
اصلاح الافساد والتجاوب مع مطالب
المتظاهرين
بتقديرك شكرا على هذا
السؤال احنا ذا ناخذ وقت حتى نخدم الناس
ونخدم الحقيقه مو حتى نشخص الحوار بيناتنا
السيد موسوي انا ما كنت جزء من
الدكتاتوريه واذا كوني نائب وقريب من رئيس
وزراء الدوله يعني انا جزء من الدكتاتوريه
وما الي حق اتحدث عنها الان الاخ حيدر
العبادي كان نائبا وعضو قيادي في الحزب
الحاكم وكان وزيرا
ايضا وله الحق ان يغير الان فال المساله
لا تشخص انها معيب هذا الكلام اثنين الى
الان ما وصلنا للحقيقه في هذا الحوار اقول
لا نستهدف استهداف الوزير او النائب غير
كافي لعمليه
التغيير النائب والوزير يحميهم
كتلهم لا يسرق وزير دون ان يطمئن لحمايه
كتلته ولذلك الهدف يجب ان يكون هي تلك
الكتل
الشريكه في تقاسم السلطه
والمنفعه الشريكه في صناعه الفشل منذ ال
2003 حتى الان ولذلك اذا كان ثمه خطوه
باتجاه التغيير حقيقيه يجب ان تتم ليس عبر
الترشيق اعفاء اربع وزارات او الغاء اربع
وزارات ولا عن طريق الدمج الدمج في بعض
الاحيان قد يكون مكافاه للفاسد دينه
والسراق يعني الكتله التي كانت تسرق من
خلال وزارتين ستسرق من خلال ثلاثه وزارات
ولذلك يجب على الشارع انلا يخدع ولا يحتوى
بهذه الاصلاحات الترقيع الاصلاح الحقيقي
يجب ان يتجسد في انسحاب الكتل واستقاله
استقاله وزراء الكتل السياسيه وتخويل ل
اخي العبادي ان يشكل حكومه لتكن مختصره
كفوء نزيهه مستقله بعيده عن
تاثيرات الشمس لا تغطى بغربال هاي محاوله
التجميل والترقيع مو منا انه رئيس الوزراء
او الحكومه يقول هذه التظاهرات ثوره نعم
ثوره رغم انفه وانف الجميع ولا يجب ان
نجامل ولا يستطيع احد مواجهتها علما اذا
اردنا ان نذيع سرا هناك حوار حقيقي وهناك
كلام دقيق بين تلك الكتل لاحتواء تلك
التظاهرات لانهم لا يريدون ان يتركوا
مواقعهم بكل صراحه نعم انت انت هنا هنا
تشير تشير الى نقطه تشير الى نقطه عفوا
تشير الى نقطه مهمه جدا اريد ان اخذ رايي
السيد الموسوي وراي السيد ابيض بسرعه فيها
باختصار في نهايه
البرنامج سيد الموسوي امكانيه الالتفاف
على مطالب الناس من قبل القوه السياسيه
امر وارد
بتقديرك لا فقط دعني اقول نحن تعودنا من
بعض الساسه يهاجم حيث عندما يتضرر ويدافع
حيث ينتفع وهذا معروف للشارع العراقي من
كان يدافع عن السيد المالكي ومن يهاجم
السيد المالكي اولا تصوير الحاله العراقيه
على انها وانها ارعبت وانها ستحقق هذا
كلام انا اعتقد فيه من قصور الرؤيه
السياسيه ما يجري هو مطالبه بتصحيح خطوط
داخل العمليه السياسيه وليس تجريف للعمليه
السياسيه ما يجري ربما سي سيد موسى ربما
انت تعكس هنا ربما تعكس انت فهم فهم فهم
السلطه لذلك ليس بالضروره هذا ما يريده
المتظاهرون ليس بالضروره هذا ولهذا اريد
ان
اريد ان اختم بسرعه مع السيد الابيض تصور
تصور المتظاهرين للهدف سيد
الابيض شوف الاخ الموسوي يحاول ان يقزم
المظاهرات ويدفعها باتجاه ثاني الحقيقه
ولكن انا اقول له بكل بساطه هذا انين
الناس قد ظهر الى الشارع ما العيب اذا كان
نظام يحترم نفسه وديمقراطيه ان يستمع
للناس وبالتالي ان لا يسوف هي كل القصه
هكذا اما محاوله انه نعطي شرعيه
ونحولها الى شرعنا هي مشكله الاساسيه في
العراق هنالك شرعنا للوجود على اساس مصالح
الناس وعلى اساس الفساد الذي ازكم الانوف
لمده 13 عام شكرا لضيوفنا احمد الابيض
جاسم الموسوي
وعزه
الشمندر دمتم في رعايه الله والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ا